one of nine from three-point territory
here in the first quarter and jeff if
you watch the knicks they are doing a
good job of picking up cage early kate
makes him pay there though his first
three of the game that's what we want to
see field goals
they're shooting five of 25 but they're
down 25 to 13. kade cunningham's got
five in the first quarter
don't stop messing with me i'm gonna go
out and buy me a weed
kate cunningham from three yes he
connects cunningham
about this play he gives it up and then
he relocates himself right if he would
have just stayed there
pays getting into the paint
is he trying to lob at the guards or
floating now he was trying to float that
but guards is active on the offense
glass i'm telling you cunningham wide
open three get his feet said he is a
tremendous shooter pistons
he got hurt in boston that knee started
acting up he was playing well for
themselves they were a better team
within
his second straight three four three
three point territory cutting him he's
got 14
it's 50 cutting him thinks about a three
eight on the shot clock cunningham now
pulls the trigger it's good
dave cunningham that's got 17.
it's been cutting ham and topping
the rookie and the second year man going
back abby chin
thanks for being with us on this friday
night cade cunningham he connects from
downtown cunningham's got 21. his six
triple of the night by luca garza on the
offensive end it's cade cunningham
it comes out again it's loose bay picks
it up over to hayes haynes in the corner
oh
look at the rookie
cade cunningham's got 24 points after
struggling over his first two games this
may be his coming out party welcome to
the nba young man